everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we're starting
our coverage of the second tournament of
the 2019 grand prix this is one of the
tournaments that's feeding into the
overall grand prix which feeds into the
candidates tournament being played next
year which i think everyone is aware the
canada's tournament the winner of that
will go on to play in the 2020 world
championship against Magnus Carlsen so
how the Grand Prix is set up there are
four tournaments we already had one
earlier in the year this is the second
one there's gonna be a third one in
early November and the last one will be
in mid-december in each of these there
will be 16 players this is a knockout
tournament which is different than some
other tournaments where you play
numerous games and then depending on how
you do against all of the field then you
have your ranking this is very different
you knock someone out to move on to the
next round and if you get knocked out
you are out of the tournament
so with that so there are 21 total
contestants in the entire Grand Prix you
don't play all of the tournaments you're
only going to be playing three of the
four so there are definitely competitors
who did not play in the first tournament
of the year so they will be playing this
tournament as well as the next two so
that is the format at the end of the
entire Grand Prix the top two finishers
will end up going to the candidates
tournament if they don't qualify through
this venue there are other opportunities
to go into the candidates tournament but
for those players who played in the
first tournament and didn't do so well
they're definitely gonna be looking to
go and do extremely well in this
tournament because they know they only
have this tournament and one others they
will have to sit out either the third or
the fourth tournament so that is a
high-level overview of the structure as
far as the players we have the top
players in the world now there are a few
exceptions Magnus Carlsen he's not gonna
be here he is the world champ
and so he declined playing in this
tournament Fabio Cara wanna another
player who he automatically has a bid in
to the candidates tournament he will not
be here
ding lien he is one of the top players
in the world not gonna be here
Vladimir Kramnik he retired so he's not
going to be playing here and then Vichy
and non he is out of this tournament by
his own personal decision he was invited
just decided not to play but our than
that we have all the top players in the
world here 16 of those so we will go
ahead and get started
starting out with round 1 we will have
coverage from every round of this
tournament MBL starts out with E 4 and
then C 6 getting into the caro-kann net
F 3 at d5 and Knight c3 this is the
2-night variation something we don't see
that often from white in the car con
Bobby Fischer's to play it when he was a
child
Bobby Fischer was a child a very long
time ago high level play not something
we currently see too often and in the
mainline continues with Bishop to ag4 so
for the just a little bit of theory that
we do have on the opening this is going
down the mainline Pont h3 and then the
Bishop takes here on F three more common
than the bishop coming to h5 because
after paani five pani six very common in
the car con then d4 this is just
solidifying the center of the board here
Bishop to e2 whitish has a really good
set up this LightSquared bishop it's
just kind of hanging out by himself
the knight here can't come to f6 very
awkward as far as how blacks going to
develop his pieces so at the end of the
day we do see navara play bishop taking
here on f3 MBO continues with the queen
taking here on f3 in the knight to f6
and then Bishop to e2 and this is a spot
where I think e 5 deserves a lot of
attention as all the players are looking
at the games being played and see how
can I find a variation that may give me
better chances in the future if I were
to come across this I think II five is a
move that a lot of players are
to be looking at it forces this night to
move here I don't think it's that great
if black tries to do the same thing
attacking the night you could take here
the pond takes here after these Knights
come off the board here you could
centralize all the bishops it doesn't
matter too much black can't really
castle on the King side because of Queen
to h5 there's just too much pressure
here eventually this is going to
collapse with both of the bishops eyeing
down here and the Queen over here white
can easily castle doesn't have too many
threats to worry about since black can't
castle I feel like white definitely has
a stronger game here you can also see
that this night here on b8 it's not
really involved into the game would
eventually like to come to c6 a little
slower if it comes here to d7 only has
one bishop white still has the bishop
here here so all I think e 5 is very
good move but decides to go ahead and
play Bishop to e2 getting ready to
castle on the kingside ecigs and then
castle on the King side as we expected
Bishop to c5 opening up for his own king
to castle on the Kings side as well now
this does open for the pawn to come down
to d4 if black does want to push in the
center we do see mvl bring his rook over
here to d1 just to protect that a little
bit
Bishop to d4 and this is where things
get pretty interesting because there was
a move not really expecting from mvl but
as we start to unpack a little bits a
fantastic move and that is Queen to f4
now let's start to unpack exactly why
this move here Queen to f4 is so
powerful the next move MBL definitely
wants to be playing to e5 attacking the
knight here on f6 this is a discovered
attack the Queen's gonna be attacking
that Bishop there on d4 so really if
black wants to hold off playing as night
until the pawn comes up here where would
the bishop go well you could definitely
exchange material here if you wanted to
but this would be exactly what MBL's
looking to do he can take back with his
pawn this opens up the door for the dark
square Bishop this rook here on d1 is
now semi opened file to control the sir
bored this does not look like what black
wants to do he has no control he has
these pauses are the board but is minor
pieces aren't doing too much there's a
lot of pressure that's gonna be
happening there's no other real Square
except for c5 and b6 both of those have
problems if we play Bishop to c5 then
pawn to d4 forcing the bishop to move
again maybe Bishop to e7
now pawn to e5 attacking at the knight
here and then Queen to g4 this starts to
get really tricky as far as both these
bishops hanging down here
you can't castle because Bishop to h6
the pawn can't take care if the pawn
moves all of a sudden the rook is gonna
fall
it just it's all not good from there if
we come back and say what happens if the
bishop comes back to b6
well then pawn up here to e5 maybe the
bishop comes to c7 could move the knight
if he wants to but this does pin down
the pawn but from here pawn to d4 just
solidifying the center of pawn chain
casts on the King side but now Queen to
g3 there's just so much pressure that
White's starting to put over here with
both these bishops eyeing down on the
King side so as we come back we do see
Navarre play correctly and he plays pawn
to e5 this does stop the threat upon
pushing forward attacks the Queen here
on f4 and also supports the Bishop on d4
Queen is forced to move so the Queen
comes back here to g3 will see the pawn
take here and this is another really
good move because a lot of players would
look at this they move their Queen back
here to g3 and immediately we take up
here to g7 but the only thing that's
gonna happen is the rooks gonna come to
g8 this pawns protected by the knight
the Knights being protected by the Queen
the Queen is gonna fall back all of a
sudden black has ass in the open file
here that he's attacking with his own
rook I'm down on the Kings side of white
black eventually castle on the Queen
side but both of his rooks here on the
King side all at all it's not a great
attack for mdl so he recognizes this and
instead plays pawn to d3
yes he's gonna end up losing a pawn in
that exchange but he doesn't really care
why because this opens up the door for
his dark square bishop begin involved
and he knows more importantly than the
material right now it's getting his
pieces involved into the attack so from
here we see the pond take which is
exactly what you know black really needs
to do is take the material and then hold
on for dear life here but then Bishop
takes on d3 just eying down more
material here so right now it's on the
h7 square black now plays Knight to d7
then the knight comes back here to e2
attacking the bishop also getting ready
to come to the King side if MVL wants to
castle on the King side for black not
too worried about the exchange here here
D is given up the bishop pair and
remember he's up material here he has
that pond in VL gave him so he doesn't
mind exchange down you always want to be
exchanging down material if you can't
yeah if you want to take my bishop
that's completely fine it's being
protected by this pawn right now the
bishop does come up here to f5 attacking
the knight and the knight comes down
here to c5 now the issue I have with
this this is completely away from the
action we've everything up to this is
leading to the King side the boards of
having more material defending that is
gonna be extremely important had lots of
different options pawn to g6 as hey get
out of my house if you want to exchange
right here that's completely fine you
don't have the bishop pair I can't
retake it with my Queen if I want I can
retake it with my knight I have
different options here even Knight to h5
right now make some sense attacking the
Queen right here instead decides to play
Knight to c5 the really only good option
you have out of this is you can
eventually bring it to East 6 it's a
little painful right now because this
does block some of the squares that the
bishop here on d4 can go to right now
it's blocked so the first thing I would
be looking at if I'm in VL standpoint is
can I play pawn to c3 and this is a
critical move as we look at it because
where can the bishop go to well as of
right now on this instant
Bishop is fairly blocked but it can come
down to f2 and this is a painful move
there's no real good way for white to
really defend against this the king
can't take here because then the Queen's
gonna come down take that rook here on
d1 and remember that Queen on d8 is a
critical square so maybe Queen comes to
e3 just trying to centralize attacking
the knight here on c5 it's gonna have to
get some material back here but in the
Knight to e5 e to e4 check okay well
that's gonna be difficult to deal with
maybe pawn to f5 attacking the bishop
also if the pawn moves it's gonna be a
discovered attack on the King here Queen
takes maybe pawn takes this is all bad
things are gonna go extremely poorly for
white at the end black's gonna easily
win this now instead of the king taking
maybe the queen takes here still gonna
be the same thing queen comes down here
check even if there is an exchange right
here it's gonna be very difficult for
white to hold on to this black still has
two rooks on board does have just the
overall material advantage he has seven
pounds to the five pawns with two rooks
and two Knights should be very easy for
him to win this in the game recognize
this and so after the knight came down
here to c5 says yeah I gotta I gotta
keep remembering this pawn to c3 here
but right now the Queen on d8 do need to
be aware of that and so does not play
pawn to c3 and set decided to play
Bishop to h6 which is exactly what Black
has prepared for he can now bring his
knight back over to e6 and he's in fine
shape still has to defend extremely well
but he misses that and he plays Knight
to h5 that is definitely not what is
going to help right now we still have
the continued pressure that white has
hey let's continue to pin down that
material here there's really only one
option here and that's Queen here to h4
you don't want to bring it up any
further because the Queen could take it
but all the pressure that was there
before it's still there
now black feels this and I feel like he
panics a little bit he plays Queen to d6
and he's
attacking the bishop and says hey if you
want to take my knight here I'll take
your bishop the problem with that is
white can easily take care on h5 after
the exchange that's exactly what White's
looking for because we do see the
exchange right here and then oh yeah
remember that one piece that we were
trying to attack earlier with pawn to c3
we couldn't do that because the Queen
here on d8 was defending that because a
bishop to f2 can no longer do that so
NBL plays pawn to c3 black recognizes
his earlier mistakes and at this point
concedes in the game so MBL play
extremely good game don't see that
to-night variation all too often seemed
like he knew exactly what to do on the
other side
David Navarro just didn't seem
comfortable the entire game made some
mistakes in the middle game and at the
end of it only after 19 moves ended up
resigning with the bishop hanging out
here just no place to go so in DL takes
a spot at the top of the leaderboard now
it's not over yet this is a best of two
so they will come back and play again so
couldn't even things up David Navarre
will have the white pieces if there is a
tie in any of these best of two series
then they go to tie breakers and they
play tie breakers if they they play a
series of tie breakers and it gets
quicker and quicker from a time
standpoint eventually they will play
Armageddon hopefully we get some
Armageddon games that we can go over
those are always fun I'll go over
exactly what that format looks like if
we have one of those but just know that
David's not out of it yet but knowing
NBL just needs a drawl does look like
with this victory he is the upper hand
going into what should be round 2 for
him so 16 going 8 and then 4 and then
the final Susan hopefully you guys
enjoyed round 1 of this tournament
remember over the next few weeks we will
have coverage from every single round I
like to go through and find maybe some
of the top players that are playing
always good to commentate on
or just some of the more interesting
games that we saw for these two players
we just didn't cover them in the first
leg of the grand priests and want to
make sure that we cover in there but
thanks again for watching and I will see
everyone in the next round